uh what advice would you give to young
people today in high school and college
how to um have a career they can be
proud of or maybe how to have a life in
general they can be proud of
I would say like
your 20s is a good opportunity to set
yourself up for the rest of your life
right so while the 20s are a period
where you want to have fun and you want
to experience youth
it's also a good opportunity to start
thinking about what do you want to what
do you want to like what do you want
your life to look like in your 30s and
your 40s right so I feel like it's the
best time to really put yourself out
there and take risks and try to hit it
you know whatever you know like to work
really really hard to set yourself up
because
and I said this at a event I was
speaking at when you're like with poker
when your bankroll is very very small
it's replenishable right
you don't need to protect it as much as
you do once you've got something right
once you have a brand or you have money
or you have something like that that's
that's when you want to start protecting
you but in your 20s is an opportunity to
just really sort of
get you know to work really really hard
to set yourself up you know for the
future I am concerned a little bit like
every time I talk to kids today I'm like
what do you want to be they all want to
be YouTubers or Instagram stars or
rappers right like okay it's like that's
cool but like there's only so many of
those that you know that there can be so
it might be worthwhile having a little
bit of a backup plan I think it's easier
to be successful on Instagram and social
media if you do something else and uh I
would say this too one other thing I
would say is
don't choose a profession or an idea
because you think it'll make you rich
yeah right
pursue something that you actually love
because if you love it you're you're way
more likely to become rich if you don't
you do something that you don't actually
enjoy now you're spending a lot of your
life unhappy doing something you don't
want and you're far and if you're not
passionate about it you're probably not
the chance of you being successful are
much lower and also becoming rich and
I've talked to a lot of rich people hang
out with a lot of rich people is not
going to be as fulfilling as you imagine
if you arrive there by not doing the
thing that you love doing that's true
ultimately the thing that you love doing
is
like that's what makes life worth
there's another quote I can't remember
who it was otherwise I would quote them
but it says something to the effect of
like
um if we believe in the lie that more is
always better then we can never truly
arrive because wherever we are more is
better right I've never understood and
I've been around rich people like you
know you said you know Bill I never got
I can't I don't get it like if you have
a billion dollars why do you give a [ __ ]
about money at all like and they're
still like oh we made this deal and I'm
like you know we picked up 300 who cares
like your life is set like there is that
bell curve right where obviously being
in poverty you know there's obviously a
high rate of unhappiness but there's a
certain amount of money where you reach
you know we reach a love of happiness
and then too much you find that people
that are searching for money to fulfill
these holes it starts to go back down
again well it the getting more money
could become a game like a sport that's
fun to play as long as you
directly or indirectly acknowledge that
what you love is the game of it uh
versus the actual attainment and I think
that's what it is right for me I've
never cared about money that much I just
never did otherwise I would have a lot
more of it but it's always like it's
always been strange to me how people
that have that kind of money like
are cheap in any way you know like they
wouldn't donate 5 000 to a worthwhile
charity because it's like buddy this
like when it changes your life not and
even like like small things like taxes
like okay you have 20 billion dollars
and you're worried about paying 33 30 to
31. I get it I get the I get the the
point of it all but like it literally
has no effect on your life whatsoever
your life is unchanged whether it's 31
or 33. yeah that's that's the negative
of a lot of money is if it corrupts the
way you see the world you start to be
protective and so on I mean part of the
challenge of when you get a lot of money
is people start to treat you differently
and so navigating that correctly is is
very challenging so don't change let's
get remain the same person you always
were because if you change you start to
I mean that's why power corrupts is you
get a lot of power you get a lot of Fame
you get a lot of money
you start to distrust people
and you start to push away people that
are actually really close I think you
develop some biases where you think like
you're just this you know you think like
it was all you and you're a genius and
you're so great and all these other
people who don't have it's just because
they don't have what you have and like
you just then you start to like view
that group of people whether they're
impoverished or whatever is like less
than and that you're some like great
Guru where you could have just got lucky
and bought Bitcoins that you know could
have done anything and then you became
like super wealthy and then you have
this like dunning-kruger effect where
you think you know everything about
everything and a lot of Poker people
have that and I listen I'm probably
guilty in some ways too you know
thinking because you can figure out
poker and be you know great at that that
you could figure out anything so there's
like it's true right I mean we sort of
we genuinely feel like people that reach
the highest levels of Poker feel like
they are intelligent so they will look
at problem solving and think that they
have answers
well you have to remind yourself that
you're not it's best to see the world as
you did just get lucky or at least from
my perspective that you're not better
than anybody I don't think there's
anything wrong with like acknowledging
that you worked hard to get where you
were like there isn't but at the same
time like it's not available to
everybody in the same way you know right
time right place like for me my poker
career could have gone very differently
you know if things didn't work out you
know if I had some bad luck in the wrong
times like who knows where I'd be so you
said uh your brain crawl is pretty small
in your 20s
I'm sure you've been around a lot of
people you care a lot about who've lost
everything in poker what's that like
what's those low points of losing
everything
I think because I've been there I have
more empathy than I probably should for
those people that really feel for them
because I remember being in Vegas and
being totally broke and like a guy
loaning me 400 and me like turning that
400 into 20 000. 400 bucks and it was
like eternally grateful of that so when
I have friends who go through that like
I always try to consult them obviously
what they really need is money for the
most part but I remember saying no to
one friend because he didn't have a plan
so I like to try to help them in that
regard like my buddy's like can you
stake me in this game and I was like all
right well how much do then I was like
let's break down the math bro you want
me to stake you so you get 50 of the
profit right so I said how much you
think you can make in this game how much
is the biggest biggest winners make it's
like well I can probably you know I
probably do like twenty thousand a month
in this game so okay so you get half of
that because I get 10 right what is your
monthly nut how much are you spending
it's like well I'm renting this thing
for eight thousand you're spending 17
000 a month
so like no matter what you're
you're set up to fail like this isn't
gonna work so I actually didn't give him
the money and I was like what you need
to do to earn more money is lower your
monthly nut because it's too high it's
just you know it just doesn't
mathematically add up so trying to set
them right in that regard is something
that like
I feel obliged to do especially if
they're friends but what about the
mental aspect of the struggle they're
going through the struggle you were
going through just uh
I mean it's it's really rough to have no
money it's not for everybody this really
isn't like a lot of people might you
know listen to this and think like oh I
want to play poker it's like most people
fail
most people who want to play in the NFL
they you know they they spend their
college Years like they're they're most
of them are not going to make it most of
you who try to play poker professionally
are going to fail and you're going to
experience despair okay there are those
like in anything that have the passion
have the know-how have the luck and all
that sort of stuff and it all pans out
but you know they're the minority
and so so for the low points if you
remember what does it take to sort of
overcome that overcome the um
the mentals struggle I mean you're
making it sound like certain people are
just genetically able to uncertain I do
think some people are more apt to being
able to deal with like adversity and
having resilience and some people just
can't hack it but like I generally what
I would advise with you know people that
are let's say a guy's playing you know
really high Stakes or whatever you're
doing badly is Step number one is take
take a little bit of a break here let's
recalibrate and let's start small again
let's you know let's restart and let's
play smaller stakes and let's get our
confidence back because in poker without
confidence you cannot be successful it
is incredibly important to have almost
an inflated level of confidence in
yourself because you're you're up
against it right as I said the majority
of people fail so why are you special
why are you different you have to be
pretty confident about your you know
yourself to think that you are one of
the chosen ones and then uh don't resist
the Despair and take a nap definitely
take a nap listen it's listen it's key
to experience it like I said yeah you're
gonna experience the spirit what else
would you what what should you be
feeling you know if things are going
poorly and you just lost all your money
excited stuff maybe like okay have your
moment of grief allow yourself to
experience it so that you can you know
reassemble there's a fundamental way in
which you haven't really lived life you
ever if you haven't experienced periods
of Despair you have a jaded view of the
world
right weird thing about the human
condition that the both the highs and
the lows are important